welcome back to new rockstars we are in
the final countdown for spider-man no
way home folks and i'm having trouble
eating i'm having trouble sleeping i
need spider-man now just like j jonah
jameson needs pictures of spider-man i
just can't take it anymore break open
the multiverse already this is rogue
theory the show where we pitch the
wildest theories for the nerdy titles
that we love my name is mt and going
wrong with me today is our very own
master of the multiverse it's jessica
clemens what's going on
i'm excited to be here thank you trebek
oh are you speaking rock bottom bottom
i don't understand
your accent
sorry spongebob jokes i love them and
also joining us is the host of the mass
effect adventure podcast it's matt
acevedo what's going on man what's up
man i dude i was like huh perfect that
was perfection it's good to be back and
finally the host of the film lost the
first podcast it's eddie villanueva
what's going on what is up guys it has
been a year of great things and we're
gonna hit this end um strong and we're
gonna talk about some spider-man we are
just days away from the premiere of
spider-man no way home in theaters next
week and this is our last rogue theory
before the release so it is time to make
some final predictions gang so that
brings us to our first topic of today
who will be the most surprising cameo in
spider-man no way huh because we're just
going to run through a list of all the
major cameos we expect to see no way
home and like discuss the likelihood
each will appear at some point during
the run time so feel free to use like a
percentage certainty here so like you
know 80
90 just put some odds on it so let's
make some final bets so let's start off
with
toby mcguire and andrew garfield as
peter parker's
what are the odds there i think that's a
easy 100
i i would bet money i will bet uh you
know i'm not a gambling man but i would
bet my fake money on this uh their
appearance i really do yeah and i think
i think i know when they're gonna appear
on both of them i definitely think both
of them are going to andrew garfield in
all of his interviews is playing like
super coy like he's like oh no stop it
i'm not in it no yeah that guy's totally
in it and so he's doing that but
he's doing a terrible job terrible job
i think so we all saw that last trailer
that last trailer
uh where i saw we saw peter falling and
like reaching for uh for uh mary j mj
right uh kind of like reflecting on like
it reminded me of like the glenn stacy
scene yeah i think right this is gonna
sound this might be like it's too
fanservicey but i think that's when
they're gonna show up which i i hate i
personally hate it but i think that's
when they're gonna show up like andrew
garfield's gonna be like no
not in this
right
i personally hate it
i i hate it but i think that's when
they're to show i'm not going to go for
two
i i have to agree with matt like i think
that's that's it's one it's one of the
most for sure things we do know despite
no confirmation of it at all
aside from you know
little clips here or there people who
have taken trailer footage from early
trailer releases you know i think that's
the one thing that we can actually say
with pretty good certainty that it's
gonna be 100 they'll be there like this
movie's just i'd be surprised if they
weren't okay so okay let let me just
like
re actually like extra clarify this
because i said andrew and toby as peter
parker is there a chance
that these two could be like a variants
of other people um different characters
or maybe potentially and this is what i
think personally
that these two could very much be
mysterio illusions because andrew
garfield is very much saying i'm not
coming back as spider-man so it's either
he's a variant or he's a mysterio
illusion so what are you what are the
odds of them coming back as like not
really
um their peter parkers but as like a
variant or just a different um type of
character i i think that would be that
would be an interesting take i don't
know if there's
if that's a real big possibility because
with everything they've done to dance
around it
i feel like
doing something like that would
completely just
dissatisfy fans all over the place like
oh you're just a mirage
you know and the fact that you have
somebody like
you have somebody like mysterio who has
no idea who these particular people are
having them come in and then having the
audience recognize them for being
spider-man but having the actual
villains in there or whatnot it would be
really really interesting to kind of get
that information into mysterious head to
be able to create that but i mean who
knows right you know we've seen worse
it's like how meta can we get like how
medic can we get in this universe maybe
like you know mysterio ends up making
the rainy spidermans and he's like oh
like oh my god that's how that would be
crazy i'd be crazy once again if that
happened i'd hate it i'd hate that and i
think it'd be a disservice if they were
just like illusions but
you never know all right so not as as
high of a likely there for you guys as
much as them being actual peter parker's
if we were supposed to put a number on
it i'd say like that one uh
thirty percent
okay thirty percent
yeah okay yeah now let's move on with
because we also got the venomverse so
tom hardy as venom eddie brock like
what is that a percent certainty there
my number is like
a 30
on that because i'm like
i don't think we're ready yet i think
we'll see it in either the next
spider-man or we'll see it in the next
venom i don't think we're gonna see it
in
i think it was just like see how like
see how crazy everything happened was
but i don't think there's so much going
on i don't think we're ready
for venom to just like jump in out of
nowhere when we're already getting all
the other villains and then we're
getting toby and we're getting andrew
garfield just like
one at a time and then i i think which
we'll get on to later i think charlie
cox will also be in it so it's like
that's too many people there's too many
people too many hands in my house yeah
too many cookies
if they're going to throw all their eggs
out in that one basket of a film i mean
sony's trying to
elongate their opportunity to hold on to
spiderman and that property and
especially that universe so they're
going to want to
tease but never fully unveil you know
and there may be mentions just like we
got in the trailer with uh morbius you
know it was like oh i am venom no i'm
just kidding like that i think is going
to be the full extent of our nod or
alluding to
they're a part of the same universe in
that film i don't know if like jess said
i don't think fans and i don't think the
studio is ready to actually show that
much of a like in proximity to each
other type of event eddie i'm not to
jump off of that i'm a little like
freaked out like i i know i'm i'm me
matt i am not ready for for tom hardy
venom to be in this universe but if i
look at the pieces like that they keep
like the morbius trailer we see we see
vulture in the morbius trailer and
that's so and and but morbius knows who
venom is so it's like like what what is
is this going to be like a combined is
this a battle world thing where they're
combining everyone is this like the
ultimate kind of like the ultimate
universe coming into the 616 universe is
this that like is this the merger like i
don't know if i'm ready for that but i
with the trailers and like with the
release of the the morbius trailer it
kind of feels like they're gonna marry
these universes and i i don't know if
i'm ready for that man it'll be
eventually i don't think it's coming
soon i think sony's like we're gonna
keep putting in nods of mcu in here
because we're coming and mcu's like okay
slow down sony
marvel's like you'll get in there
eventually just wait your turn we still
got all everybody's got that kevin feige
look when they're like oh they're going
to be a part of the same universe
yeah yeah
i feel like if you keep taking your hat
to it you'll eventually yeah
because when we see venom he's he he's
he comes to the mcu and he sees on
screen peter parker spider-man like but
i don't know that interaction like i
don't know how he's gonna like why would
he go after this like spider-man like it
just feels so
from the outside not being in the
writer's room it's like it just feels so
forced to me and i'm like i'm nervous
about it because i love how eddie brock
was introduced originally into the
spider-man universe and this feels like
it just feels a little look a little
hokey for me well and i've already
mentioned like aside from that little
clip at the end of it of the morbius
trailer you also have them mentioning
like oh this is as freaky as a thing
that happened in san francisco or
whatever what not like alluding to the
events that happened in san francisco
i.e with eddie brock and everything else
or whatever that illusion is towards um
i i think i don't think we're going to
get
any
mention of venom or not mention no
vision of a physical representation of
venom but i do think we're going to get
maybe an illusion or a you know mention
of it because i think they're saving a
lot of that for morbius i think morbius
is going to be the one that really kind
of shows that side of the anti-hero uh
squad if you will and and push more
towards that it's a great conversation
because i legitimately i don't know how
they're going to pull this off like i
don't think he's going to show up what
do you guys i don't think he's going to
show up
you don't think he's going to show up
okay so like what do you guys think of
the possibility of you know we know in
the trailers that doctor strange says
we've had some visitors but we don't
know the visitors that dr strange ran
into before he charges peter with um
doing
you know fixing his own mistakes so
essentially what if uh venom tries to
like get peter because he thinks he's a
criminal and then he's like all right
and then doctor strange is like oh what
are you doing you can't be here you got
you're bad you gotta go back to your
your box so back to the sony version
and so i mean i just feel like there's
an opportunity for
venom to just go and try to get peter
parker um because he's trying to be a
lethal protector and he's being
portrayed as this villain um so i think
there is a spot for venom and we did see
those uh those pictures of tom hardy
with the hat
that is so hardy would be no way oh man
if it'll be in there i think it'll just
be at the very end it'll be at the very
end i think it'll be in a credit scene
but that's it and it may not even be
venom himself it might just be tom hardy
saying hey
talk yeah it might be all right yeah
i also think
if they run into each other it's not
going to be like uh
you know
they're not going to be rivals or
enemies i think he's going to help
whatever the cause is in this situation
uh maybe something happens where they
you know or the symbiote maybe takes an
attraction to
i don't remember where they left off in
venom i think they resolved their their
relationship issues venom and and uh and
eddie brock but oh yeah they were on a
honeymoon together yeah exactly that's
right that's right but i think i don't
know man like they're gonna team up
first before
i don't think we're gonna they're gonna
hate each other in the beginning all
right so what about charlie cox as matt
murdock the daredevil man what are the
odds of him showing up in spider-man no
way home that just seems like a really
that would be a great fan service type
thing and with everything that's been
released and all the leaks and
everything else uh aside from that i
feel like it would be a really strong
contender for being a part of that
universe like to show up because charlie
cox has been the one of the strongest uh
front runners in terms of popularity for
the netflix
uh marvel front absolutely and so a lot
of people knowing that charlie cox is
super into the idea of coming back and
reprising his role and and doing the
daredevil you know
character all over again with them i
feel like it's just a matter of time i
feel like it's going to be in the film i
don't know if we'll get him get a
glimpse of him in the full suit but i
feel like we'll get a glimpse of charlie
cox uh as matt murdock i
want charlie cox to be in it i don't
think he'll this will be his appearance
i kind of think
like this is a for me i see i see this
as a great opportunity for she-hulk for
jennifer walters to make an appearance
because she in the comics she represents
uh she's a defense lawyer for
superheroes so this is like kind of up
her alley uh so i think i don't think
she'd be she he'll get but maybe just
like that i forgot who's playing who was
confirmed to play her but maybe she
shows up as like you know not as
she-hulk but as jennifer walters to
represent spider-man in this case that's
actually a good point it's a very good
point because yeah she did represent
superheroes and this is pretty much the
few times where you know superheroes in
the hot seat like this yeah um so yeah
no for sure what about you jess what
what are your percentages i think it's
100 i also just really am holding on to
that
like him being his lawyer scene and also
kevin feige being like yes he's gonna
have a place in the mcu i think it's
because it's like it's starting with
spider-man they're gonna have his little
nod of like hey i'm a lawyer
you don't know i'm a superhero hey i'm a
lawyer i'm a lawyer hey i'm a lawyer and
peter's like oh my god i'm in the
shadows like alfred hitchcock i'm a
lawyer no but i think he will i think he
will i think he will and that's the one
there's two people that i think are
gonna show up that i have completely no
evidence of i just want to and i really
think they could and i think charlie cox
is one of them this is a great
introduction again a reintroduction of
him again um especially to the big
screen i i think so yeah i think so i'm
gonna say a hundred i'll put money on it
two dollars though only two dollars
two dollars yeah two real dollars not
fake money real money um
all right guys so what about emma stone
as gwen stacy or kirsten dunst as mary
jane i don't think we'd get either but i
feel sorry i was like i don't think we
either but i think we get we'd more get
emma stone as gwen stacy then we'd get
kirsten dunst as mj yeah and the
reasoning behind that is because in the
trailer
like it's everyone that spider-man has
killed right technically gwen stacy was
killed by spider-man so it might be true
right yo hey yo if if when stacy shows
up because
technically andrew garfield killed her
that would be some really harsh stuff
for andrew garfield to actually deal
with because like the universe is saying
it's your fault you did it it wasn't him
it was you yeah that would be harsh that
would be so harsh on a cosmic level
really don't know man that's a crazy
idea yeah i agree if there's ever an
opportunity christian dunn's probably
not
uh likely at all but emma stone does
have some
dubs does have some like skin in the
game in terms of obviously like matt
mentioned you know at the hands of
spider-man so but to what extent would
be the interesting dilemma like would we
get
kind of how we got with uh into the
spider-verse where uh kingpin was trying
to bring back find a way to bring back
his wife from another universe and he
just got glimpses are we going to get
like full gwen stacy are we going to get
glimpses is that going to be something
that is a part of the journey for andrew
garfield spider-man in this one in the
film itself you know recognizing
obviously you know oh if these are the
ghosts of you know that are at my hands
then you know
you know this is something that i have
to
hold myself accountable to kind of thing
um yeah but yeah i think emma's known is
more likely i don't know how strong of a
percentage i think that holds maybe like
25 possibility
i don't think very high because then
like we were saying there's already so
much going on in this film there's gonna
be so many different characters we're
gonna have to be attaching ourselves to
and watching and following with the
journey adding that as a part of the
whole storyline uh might be a bit
precise
the only pl bonus i would give to them
the only knot i'd give to them for this
is if they did like spider gwen and it
was like emma stone now as spider-gwen
just because it's like her aging and i
would be like oh my god this is so fun
but i don't think emma stone would be
like yeah okay i'm okay with playing
this very small role
right
i do hear me out and i don't think this
is gonna happen but if there was a nod
to kirsten dunst where it's just like in
the background now in the in spider-man
2 she was on broadway and it was like
her movie poster or like her theater
poster everywhere
of her in
i would love that at least that please
marvel please that would be so great
she's actually in the cast for rogers
and musical so
oh yeah
that'd be so good that would actually
just be funny if toby mcguire's
spider-man were just the film spider-man
so the in a in some kind of alternate
universe he is just this the famous
spider-man he's just like i'm just a
celebrity i'm not actually
spider-man my movies just took off i
shouldn't be here right now if that was
ever a case i would lose my [ __ ] and i
wouldn't be mad i wouldn't be mad
okay we're just gonna we're gonna rapid
fire these next ones yeah i'm just like
hit me with the percentage and like a
quick reason why um you feel that way
but
vincent d'onofrio's kingpin i mean
that's the big this big name these days
your name these days
yeah low like maybe twenty percent
depends on if he's a black kid in um if
he is the black kid in
because if he is the black kid and hot
guys they cannot be vincent
karate kid
yeah i think very low for that one too
yeah okay yeah it does make sense i feel
like that's more of a hawkeye thing so
yeah i would say low as well um
elizabeth olsen at scarlet witch won a
maximum
postcard for me
yeah post credit as well that's where
i'm at that's right
post credits
uh we already have doctor strange as the
mystical being in this one and doing all
the the stuff to have someone like wanda
come in and kind of overpower that would
be
like i said stretching a bit i think
she's going to show up in the doctor
strange one i think she'll be post
credits uh you know because this is
technically part one of right they said
that like multiverse would technically
be part two of this story so i think
she'll show post credits and do
something
maybe she'll just be like uh
i need your help no no that's that's my
poster
why don't you have a deep voice i need
your
help they're just pretty much
re-enacting that scene from justice
league
yeah yeah exactly
[Laughter]
oh man but i think that's where it's
gonna happen for i just gonna be like i
need your help and that's that's like
we got this hard new jersey i need your
help oh no i need your help
it's strange i need jail
then mountain's over and god knows her
all right how about any of the x-men
like any of the the fox x-men yeah
these are very i think
it would be a lot for one movie and i
know that spider-man threes do have the
tendency to cram things in but i think
that would be way too much to put up the
any of the x-men
yeah as because we already have netflix
elements and all these sony elements
that all right yeah i would explode i
would explain yeah frankly um
i think that's a 14
605 chances of that and only one of them
i saw you using the time stone before
the show i was wondering what you were
doing
now i know
[Laughter]
and finally how about a newly cast
live-action miles morales or like we
brought up earlier gwen stacy hi i think
mama's morales show up let me tell you
let me tell you i think it's way too
soon but what i love about the st the
ending credits the post-credit scenes
are like things i just didn't i was like
how are they going to jump that quick
like the end of venom i was like oh [ __ ]
yeah we are we're starting i didn't know
we were starting already this is gonna
take like two more years i was like and
then i was like
i was like oh my god it's like there's
other so many properties and we need to
start first so i was like i was i love
those post credit scenes i've never
prepared for them even in eternals i was
like oh my god what like i'm not
prepared for them so i think this is one
that also comes from the [ __ ] left
field because i want everybody to go
back into their holes go back to their
times but i want him to end up going
back to school everything's back to
normal he runs into another kid drops
papers looks up and he goes sorry i'm
new here my name is miles and i go
because he didn't go back in his portal
i think he stays in this timeline and i
want that to be like something we see i
want him to just show up at his school
be going to the same school just
transferred miles morales like
oh so miles miles i'm holding on to very
satisfying
and it makes sense because aaron davis
was teased and like it's just the seeds
are there
not trying to rush but also like sony
just drop the trailer mcu hurry up like
try to beat them to the movie uh so
they're trying it's like what better
rush than this putting it in right now
did anyone else feel like i felt like
that i also would love miles to show up
i don't i think it's gonna if he did it
would be like that quick you know like
just just as jessica said exactly like
that like a quick oh crap he's here you
know holy crap
i i think there's a i would say of
i'm gonna say i'm gonna say fifty
percent on that one okay fifty fifty
four four miles specifically yeah and i
would love that i would like we already
confirmed that he's in this universe you
know with aaron davis as uh uh donald
glover you know and and and starting at
homecoming like i got uncle or our
nephew in brooklyn you know like like
that's that's miles he's here yeah he's
here yeah yeah he's around yeah i don't
think one states you though i don't
think we'll get spider-gwen i think
we'll get spider-gwen yeah i would love
at the very least if we just saw some
graffiti from miles like somewhere that
we'd like to be like yeah that'll be
something to pay attention to
i would love that at the very least just
put that in marvel if it's not in there
already just put it in watch miles have
done the graffiti of iron man when he
died in the second phase oh my god tell
me that was true
marvel
tell me that was true
that is an amazing idea
wow i love that so much like oh imagine
if it was him and his uncle
they would totally yeah
together
yo
my god anyway you guys are all amazing
these are all amazing percentages you
guys have amazing thoughts i love all
you guys you guys are so smart so smart
um so all of you guys get the equal
amounts of points i guess i i don't even
think we can award points we're just
getting really yeah
but anyways up next we will try to
predict what comes after no way home
because we i mean this is what we do
here but first there is a new latest
obsession shirt inspired by hawkeye
available at new rockstarsmerch.com it
has a really cool design comes in three
colors which is the highest number there
is three and is officially the best
shirt to wear while watching new hawkeye
episodes featuring haley steinfeld and
the winking dog so find these shirts and
all the great merch options over at
newrockstarsmerch.com but hey
cryptocurrency might feel like at a
secret or exclusive club but coinbase
believes that everyone everywhere should
be able to get in the door so whether
you've been trading for years or just
getting started coinbase can help so
coinbase offers a trusted and easy to
use platform to buy sell and spend
cryptocurrency and they support the most
popular digital currencies on the market
and make them accessible to everyone and
they offer portfolio management and
protection learning resources and a
mobile app so you can trade securely and
monitor your crypto all in one place
millions of people in over 100 countries
trust coinbase with their digital assets
so whether you're looking to diversify
just getting started or searching for a
better way to access crypto markets
start today with coinbase and for a
limited time new users can get ten
dollars in free bitcoin when you sign up
today at coinbase.com
rogue sign up at coinbase.com rogue for
ten dollars in free bitcoin this offer
is for a limited time only so be sure to
sign up today that's coinbase.com
rogue and hey also we recently just got
some socks from stands and they're both
incredibly comfortable and also well
designed they feel great and they're
unique and my feet have never looked
more hip my feet feel special for once
in their lives founded in 2009 stance
apparel represents a radical reinvention
of socks underwear in active apparel
with a sharp focus on comfort quality
and creativity stance brings an atypical
aesthetic alongside some of pop
culture's hottest collaborators for the
ultimate in style and self-expression
because everything you wear should be a
direct expression of who you are and how
you feel and they have a lot of stylish
collaborations with brands you love and
they currently have sock collaborations
with you know marvel pixar and star wars
and they have other collabs with the wu
tang clan they ain't nothing to mess
with major league baseball and all kinds
of cool designers and i'm planning on
wearing a pair of buddy of yell socks
around the house on christmas to impress
my family and any delivery drivers that
catch a glimpse dance believes that the
perfect fit matters more than fitting in
that those who feel good do good so go
see for yourself register for an account
at stanz.com and get 15 off your first
purchase use promo code rogue at
checkout to apply enjoy the color and
comfort of a life less ordinary with
stance and there's not a lot of time
left for holiday shopping and that's
where faraday comes in they have gifts
for everyone on your list verity is a
family-run brand making high quality
timeless clothing with modern design and
functionality so you know when you're
searching for the coziest gifts that are
practical and cool flannels that feel
like you've had them for years
expedition ready parkas super soft
sweaters and cords well that's verity
several staff members have ferry clothes
that they absolutely love and they look
great and feel great true story
off-screen producer zack recently heard
famous director judd apatow at a live
comedy show say that they're his
favorite brand of shirt and judd would
not lie not once would he do that
they're so confident in the quality of
their stuff that they have a lifetime
guarantee of quality and they replace or
fix your clothes forever no matter what
and on top of it all farady is giving
all rogue theory listeners twenty
percent off right now twenty percent off
that is two zero percent off and you've
probably heard this already but thanks
to this pandemic shipping delays are
going to be major this year so start
shopping now to get all of your gifts
before the holidays head to
fairitybrand.com rogue and use code
rogue at checkout to get 20 off your
first purchase that's code rogue at
ferrity f a h e r t y
b r a n d
dot com slash rogue for twenty percent
off period
that's the end i don't know why i
thought i was gonna save more now now it
is time for our second topic of the day
which is more spider-man stuff guys what
are your spider-man no way home
post-credit scene predictions because
it's a marvel tradition we're gonna have
some post-credits scenes so like okay
give me your predictions for a
mid-credit scene in a post-credits scene
or if you can only do one then one is
fine but like it'd be cool if you could
do two but i could do two i got you so
all right
mid-credit zine would be
uh hilariously at the end of everything
peter and uh tom hall and peter and mj
decide to move in together they find
this apartment you get a knock at the
door it's the landlord it opens the door
and it's actually uh mr mr dikkovic from
spiderman
or three i think spiderman three
and uh have him come back because i i
don't know if you guys know but that was
sam raimi's homage to steve ditko uh in
that film so to bring him back would be
really cool to kind of come full circle
like uh if promises were or crack or
crackers my daughter would be fat guy
kind of whole thing you know
that would be my mid credit uh my end
credit would be if
uh spiderman somehow is is
talking with doctor strange and then
something happens and a portal opens up
and then tom finds himself in the
miles morales uh second film
of the uh
into the spider-verse sequel that's sick
yeah hey that wasn't mine but that is
sick
and i want that to happen sony would do
it and like everyone would love sony for
it and like you know we do have that
part two coming after part one yeah
let's get it going let's get it popping
i love it i love it what do you got what
else we got what else we got give me a
second i also picked a hangnail so i'm
bleeding
like sometimes you just gotta like bite
your lip and pull you know
i hate hanging nails so much
okay so yeah yeah obviously i clearly
want miles morales to jump in but this
is now for rogue points so
take that take that out of here take
that out of here i think a good
mid-credit scene for the way i want
carol danvers and monica to show up so
much destruction has happened i feel
like it's time for carol danvers to show
up randomly and be like
okay
too many holes have opened in the world
and i'm seeing them in the middle of
outer space i know that we're trying to
see them when we see nick fury next but
i think they're gonna come through in
this part as just like a tee up for like
this is a big deal no one's really
working on it if it's taking up three
movies then they should bring in more
people so i think this is where monica
will probably show up and be like yo you
guys all [ __ ]
no i think that's a really good idea um
considering that if you think about
avengers end game um
all these energies
are coming from earth and so like our
earth is like making so much noise on a
cosmic scale that so many people are
probably
so many aliens are probably super
curious about what's going on on earth
so if we have another huge cosmic blast
with whatever happened over the statue
of liberty i'm sure carol's gonna be
like uh we got to be quiet because we're
just we're attracting too much attention
and people think that we're cooler than
we actually are yeah
and i think for a post-credits scene
and this is a honestly this is just as
kooky as the miles morales if not just
completely crazy i think as everything
is kind of settled down it's quiet we're
like on an alley and then out of the
trash pops deadpool and he's like what i
miss like what's going on
and that's how we finally get our
introduction and connection oh my god i
would [ __ ] myself i would poop my pants
i would put myself that would be the
biggest
out of nowhere i would love it i would
absolutely love it oh my god or if he
fell through his own little portal
like maybe they thought they cleaned it
all up and then he just falls through
and falls into the trash and when he
gets out of the trash it's deadpool yeah
if you're telling me that the next
spider-man movie is spider-man and
deadpool that would sell up a jillion
because like we don't get actually
resolution at the end of the second
deadpool movie when he's traveling
through
uh not just because all we know is just
time
but maybe through the course of whatever
happens in spider-man maybe we get like
a slight glimpse of something of like
while he's traveling it gets bumped into
another you know universe timeline and
then shows up i mean that would be
really cool and that'd be a really
interesting way for them to introduce
them
where's the bald man in the wheelchair i
got to go look for him he knows the
answer
oh yeah i think i so these can be kind
of enter or reverse i don't like i i do
think there will be like a funny one in
the middle and this is pretty funny
you don't have to say that because i
just set myself up for it to not be
funny anyways
but i think these can be uh you can flip
these right so the first one uh is it's
uh
i think there's definitely going to be a
connection with uh you know with doctor
strange and it might be this will be at
the very very end uh at the last credit
scene it's like doctor strange is like
you know like they got all the
spider-man villains away but there's
some of like things aren't right things
there's things are not right and that's
when walks through uh one of the portals
is uh shanghai and katie walk through
like like because you know they talked
about how the rings were like the center
there's like a beacon and i think it's
gonna tie into uh multiverse and madness
i think that we'll see a glimpse of that
um and how this movie because we you
know peter messed up everything and then
it caused something to trigger in those
rings so i think we'll see something
along those lines and then the other
post-credits scenes is because things
are back to normal something like not
like i think we're going to see remnants
of like
the sony universe coming over and
they're they're here forever now uh and
i think you know i do agree with eddie
that i think mj and peter will probably
like move in together or something uh
but they're like oh we need a job so
peter's gonna go work at the daily bugle
uh and he'll like be like uh he'll be
like oh i can take pictures of things i
can take pictures and they just and then
and then uh j james is like oh yeah what
what do you think you got and then he'll
look down at the photo on the newspaper
and it's more bs and it's like vampire
in new york and he's like uh i could
take pictures of spider-man with morbius
or that guy right there and he's like oh
get on my desk tomorrow morning i think
that will be like the connection to
you know
the rest of this the sony universe
coming in with the mcu officially
those are my two i like that you brought
up um the the possibility of a shanxi
spider-man team up because i really i
have a huge proponent for
uh shengshi and spider-man to be in a
movie together with martin lee and uh
symbiote because like exactly it's
literally perfect literally you can tie
it all together and like oh man i just
want to see martin lee on screen because
i think he's a really great spider-man
villain no these are all amazing
theories but i'm gonna have to give uh
the rogue point here to my man eddie
because tom holland inside of the end of
the spider verse 2
or
in any inner the spider-verse sequel i
need it i need it inside of my eyeballs
um and he would be great i would love to
see a little cartoon tom holland can't
get enough of tom holland he's a he's
america's treasure wait no he's not from
america he's written london
i would love it if he like it was even
if he wasn't anime he got like roger
rabbited into like that universe you
know i would love it bro it would be
great it would be so cool the first
thing he meets is spider pig and it's
just like it'd be great
what are you doing here but yes these
were all great answers but before we
continue guys there is nothing sexier
than confidence and blue chew can help
give you confidence where it counts
luchu is a unique online service that
delivers the same ingredients as viagra
and cialis but wait are you guys
laughing at the bluetooth thing
is laughing yeah just the segway that
was oh yeah segway
blue chew is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
chewable tablets in at a fraction of the
cost you can take them any time day or
night just take them responsibly so you
can plan ahead or be ready whenever an
opportunity arises the process is simple
sign up at bluetooth.com consult with
one of their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you'll receive
your prescription within days and the
best part it's all done online so no
visits to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations and no waiting in line at
the pharmacy blue chews tablets are made
in the usa and prepared and shipped
direct to your door in a discreet
package so if you could benefit for some
extra confidence when it's time to
perform blue chew can help and we've got
a special deal for our audience try blue
chew free when you use our promo code
rogue at checkout just pay five dollars
shipping that's bluechew.com promo rogue
to receive your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank blue chew for sponsoring the show
now guys now it is time for our rogue
question of the day and now
as we all know kevin feige made all of
our dreams come true when he has
confirmed that the mcu's daredevil will
be charlie cox himself we just don't
know when he's going to appear but we
know when he does appear the horns will
be over the head of charlie cox
amazing thank you kevin feige we love
you forever so pitch me your rogueis
theories on how daredevil could make his
debut inside of the mcu other than me
pitching in spider-man i think the best
part and what i want to see him in is
she hope i want to see him go
head-to-head with she-hulk i want to
either work together with her or i want
them to work against each other i want
them to both be defending the wrong
people um and i want it it will be so
fun to watch these two superheroes that
either know that they are they have
powers or know that they don't have
powers going at it like in real life by
day and then at night going against each
other or what have you but i just think
that world's already set up for a lawyer
um why not throw charlie cox in there
perfect
we're in the law phase of the mcu yeah
yeah
the multiverse
bring me to legal action
there you go jess i was i was also gonna
say it's gonna be in she-hulk because
that makes the most sense to me unless
doctor strange wants to make a new
defenders
hey he was on the defenders team in the
comics yeah and he gets like some people
in and stuff like that uh another way he
could come in maybe like because uh it
might be miss marvel right because like
what if uh if kamala doesn't know like
she like is scared about her powers or
something like that like maybe she
destroys something or it might be
something like the superhero uh children
act that was like recent in comics just
the name i'm blanking on but i was like
superheroes uh kids shouldn't be
superheroes right maybe he shows up
there to like help her out you know so
that could be a cool intro too let's see
because oh my god you guys jess you
killed it with that answer yeah
absolutely
it's true
to be honest like i want to see so to be
quite frank i want to see charlie cox in
a major film like i want to see him on
the big screen i want to see him be
revealed in the way that just really
highlights exactly what we've known for
this entire time is that charlie cox as
matt murdock slash daredevil is an
amazing character um i i would almost
kind of push to say like
maybe a great opportunity where we see
him kind of headline the film alongside
with like blade um like i would like to
see him come out in that opportunity uh
showcasing you know where the hangout of
some of the vampires are like in hell's
kitchen and blade has to team up to a
certain extent with the the local
avenger in that area the local uh you
know fighter and he finds charlie cox's
you know daredevil and they go and they
try to start eliminating some of those
dens of vampires and things like that in
hell's kitchen like i feel like that
would be a really great way to to
highlight charlie cox and really get him
to to be more than just a
you know appearance but actually
show that he's got longevity in the mcu
further down the road that kind of that
sparked an idea for me
yeah you know go for it this is that's
why i love having a conversation with
you guys because i i just remember the
iron hearts coming out ryan when yeah
first comes onto the scene she's like
you know people think she stole this
tech and all this stuff from tony stark
so maybe she gets into a legal dispute
and charlie cox daredevil is actually
not a bad guy but he's like the defense
lawyer against against riri uh you know
i mean that's when he shows up real but
then realizes like the people that he's
representing are actually messed up and
then he has a change of heart but maybe
that that could also be a fun place for
him to show up uh it's against riri in
the beginning but then like change his
sides because i forgot i forgot iron
hair was coming out i really like i
wanted the second eddies because i was
like it would be really fun
to see him teaming up with blade
especially if him and blade are friends
because i think this blade's all
slightly different than what we saw in
like the 90s clearly
that i think he's still
doing what he's doing legally i think
because of eternals what we saw him
working with um kit harrington i think
it's like we still are gonna like try to
stay
on the law's end of things a little bit
uh you're working with such a rich
person it's kind of hard to like stay
off the radar messing with rich people
so i think he's going to be like friends
with uh daredevil just so he can say
straight up like hey
listen here they're on your tail they're
on like they're coming for you you got
to do something about it and would be
really fun to see them as like a team i
would love i would
eat that [ __ ] up i would also love a
daredevil um link up with uh the more
mystical street fighters like your
blades because oh yeah elektra elektra
is like she is this person that
resurrects in the comics and i feel like
you can easily tie daredevil to the
blade universe with the land and all
that and i i'm more hyped about the the
possibility of elektra honestly because
you know that elektra's coming she was a
fantastic part of that show yeah but um
out of all these answers i'm gonna have
to give it to jess because that was just
too good it's just yeah hulk is the best
is gonna be so good and so fun
you know what i'm going to say because
because we got good answers from matt
earlier i'm gonna say everybody wins
this episode that was a pity vote matt
that was a pity vote
that was
everyone gets a point we're all winners
because we're getting spider-man very
very all winners in jesus
yes happy holidays we all get spider-man
spider-man the matrix can't wait there
you go oh my god the matrax yes uh there
is no spoon everybody but that is it for
this episode of rogue theory thank you
so much to our guests jessica clemens
matt acevedo and eddie valenueva please
support them wherever they are follow
them on twitter they're all amazing
amazing people and support our channel
by checking out all of our awesome merch
at
newrockstarsmerge.com and hey if you
want to talk more about this episode on
rogue theory search for us on discord
and join some of the channels that we've
opened up to the public so if you're
over 18 and interested search for the
new rockstars discord server and join
the conversation again you can follow me
at mastertame if you want to see me
tweet some really weird [ __ ] follow the
rockstars on all social platforms and be
sure to subscribe to our channel here on
youtube we'll see you guys next time we
love you guys so much thank you so much
for watching and having fun with us uh
we'll see you guys later goodbye
[Music]
you